a photo posted to Marvel Studios
Instagram and Twitter accounts featuring
most of the MCS female characters on the
set of Avengers endgame has stoked the
ire of fans why
well not for who it does include but for
who it doesn't along with a few key crew
members the black-and-white photo
features the vast majority of the MCS
women posing and smiling for the camera
including tonight Carrera as Ocoee
Elizabeth Olsen as Scarlet Witch Gweneth
Paltrow as Pepper Potts brie Larson is
Captain Marvel Evangeline Lilly as the
wasp Leticia right to Cherie palm
Clementi up as mantas Zoe Saldana as
Gamora and Karen Gillan is nebula but
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow and
Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie are missing in
action there is of course a good reason
for this due to scheduling conflicts
Thompson's Valkyrie had to be digitally
inserted into her scenes during endgames
climactic battle meaning that she wasn't
excluded simply unavailable as for Black
Widow well spoiler alerts Black Widow
took a swan dive off a clip on the alien
planet to form ear
the good news is that she managed to
retrieve the soul stone for Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye the bad news is that
the character bit the big one and
couldn't join in the big fight against
Thanos during the movies climax this
being the case there was obviously no
earthly reason for Johansson to be on
set the day that this photo was taken as
you can plainly see the cast and crew
were in the midst of shooting that big
final battle by which point Johansson's
contribution to the film was complete
sure somebody could have given her a
ring and invited her to come back down
to the set to pose for this lovely shot
with her cast mates but we're talking
about a world famous a lists actress who
just might have had another professional
engagement on the day they decided to
snap an impromptu photo of course
knowing this didn't keep fans on social
media from completely losing their minds
over the totally understandable
exclusions complicating matters is the
fact that many fans have widely
speculated that the all-female team up
seen in endgame was only meant to tease
the imminent arrival of a movie based on
a force a team of super-powered women
introduced in the pages of Marvel Comics
in 2016 one fan even promised an
uprising if Black Widow were to be
excluded from such a project should it
ever actually materialize tweeting a
swear to God at the a horse move II is
made without
Tahlia a leonova Romanova we riot that
of course completely disregards the fact
that the character is you know dead and
that her forthcoming solo film is pretty
much guaranteed to be a prequel and to
say that this was the only such tweet to
light up the internet as the result of
this photo would be an understatement
of course for every fan ready to burn
down the internet over their favorite
Lady Avengers being missing from the
shots there was at least one more
jumping in to help Lee point out that
neither of them were on set that day
this fact rather than some nefarious
photo excluding conspiracy was likely
the reason for their absence but
apparently there simply aren't enough
things in the world for some people to
get worked up over which is the only
reason we can think of for there to be
any controversy of any type whatsoever
over this perfectly charming photo for
its part Marvel Studios has not
commented on the kerfuffle because of
course it hasn't this is just Twitter
being Twitter obviously we're hoping for
a neighbor's movie just as hard as
anyone else but let's not declare such a
project an absolute failure if it
doesn't completely satisfy every single
member of its intended audience
fortunately Marvel Studios takes its
marching orders from Kevin Feige who has
yet to steer the studio wrong and who
knows maybe an A Force movie could do
the hard work of tasking its characters
with the tough job of somehow bringing
Black Widow back to life
it worked for Superman and Justice
League right do you feel a sense of
confidence that we're not doing
something horribly wrong and McCobb here
no really
on second thoughts never mind check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the MCU or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]